نبدا من صحيفه الجاردن حيث تقول ان
التقارير تفيد بتصاعد القتال في انحاء
السودان ما يعد مؤشرا على عنف مكثف منتظر
في الايام المقبله ويقول محللون انه من
غير المرجح اي يؤدي تمديد الهدنه لمده 72
ساعه اخرى الى فتره راحه كبيره للمدنيين
المنهكين اليائسين بعد 12 يوما من الصراع
الذي اودى بحياه المئات وادى الى كارثه
انسانيه تلوح في الافق مجله
ان الافاق قادمه بشان مستقبل السودان فقد
ادى الصراع بين الجنرلين المتنافسين عبد
الفتاح البرهان ومحمد حمدان دقلو الى
تقويض الجهود الرميه للانتقال الى
الديمقراطيه بشكل كامل ويقول محللون
السودانيون للمجله انهم يتوقعون ان يؤدي
الاجلاء الجماعي للاجانب الى تصعيد
البرهان وحميدتي معركتهما من اجل السي على
العاصمه الخرطوم مع الحرص على تجنب خسائر
في صفوف المدنيين بخلاف ما حدث في الايام
الاولى للقتال وراى الكاتب ديفيد بيلينج
في مقاله
التفاؤل الشديده التي سادت بعد الاطاحه
بنظام عمر البشير كانت مجافيه للواقع
المرير فرغم اصاله الحركه التي خرج فيها
مئات الالاف الى الشوارع لشهور المتحده
غير قادره على ضمان سلامه هؤلاء موقع ذا
هيل قال ان روسيا تعمل على تاجيج حده
الصراع وصب الزيت على النار في السودان
كجزء من خطه مجموعه فاغنر للمرتزقه الروس
للتوسع في جميع انحاء افريقيا ويخطط زعيم
المجموعه
في القتال للسيطره على السودان وتقديم
الاسلحه الى الجماعات شبه العسكريه
[موسيقى]